this is hoover dam built on the colorado
river in the 1930s it created the
country's largest reservoir lake mead
water and hydroelectric power from here
made the modern west possible
but look at the light-colored bathtub
ring around the shoreline that's how far
the water level has receded
scientists say the lake is at 35 percent
capacity its lowest level ever
scientists say global warming has
contributed to a decades-long drought
that's drying up the west this is the
second worst 19-year period going back
1200 years
that's a mega drought the u.s
government's declaration of a water
shortage on the colorado river is
unprecedented the fact that we are
seeing the first declaration
is
quite significant historically
40 million people in the region depend
to some degree on this water in booming
cities like phoenix and las vegas san
diego and los angeles water supplies to
cities will not be cut but agricultural
allocations will now farmers like will
thielander in arizona face a crisis
we're losing about half our deliverable
water potentially next year so
gonna have to cut back on a lot of acres
that we're having production right now
government officials say climate change
is at the root of the water shortage
and it's not just here at lake mead in
recent months the punishing effects of
global warming have been made brutally
clear all over the american west
unprecedented heat waves have hit the
normally cool pacific northwest monster
wildfires have ravaged california and
oregon the water level in one of
california's biggest reservoirs lake
oroville is so low the dam can no longer
produce hydroelectric power
in the columbia river huge numbers of
migrating salmon sickened and died
because the water simply became too hot
for them on tuesday the southern
california water authority issued an
alert calling on consumers to
voluntarily conserve water and prepare
for continued drought
all of which raises questions about
sustainability as scientists predict the
dryness and the heat will continue
rob reynolds al jazeera at hoover dam